hablemos ahora del que es por mucho el
teorema más famoso de todas las
matemáticas y me estoy refiriendo al
teorema de pitágoras teorema
teorema
d
pitágoras teorema de pitágoras y tiene
que ver con triángulos rectángulos
triángulos que tienen un ángulo de 90
grados de la manera como lo dibujé aquí
este es el ángulo de 90 grados y la
manera distinguir un ángulo de 90 grados
si nunca has visto uno antes es que si
este lado va de izquierda a derecha este
otro lado va de abajo arriba son
perpendiculares estos lados este ángulo
de 90 grados o un ángulo recto y el
teorema de pitágoras nos dice que si
estamos trabajando con un triángulo
rectángulo déjame escribir esto
este es un triángulo rectángulo no es un
triángulo rectángulo es un triángulo
rectángulo un triángulo que tiene un
ángulo recto un triángulo en el cual uno
de sus ángulos mide 90 grados entonces
la relación que tiene entre sus lados es
la siguiente
si este lado le llamamos a a este lado
le llamamos b y este lado le llamamos ce
y aquí lo importante es notar que este
lado ce es el que es opuesto al ángulo
de 90 grados es muy importante tomar en
cuenta la disposición de los lados el
teorema de pitágoras nos dice que si y
sólo si éste es un triángulo rectángulo
entonces se cumple que a cuadrada más b
cuadrada va a ser igual a ser cuadrada y
la manera de aplicar esta información es
si conocemos dos de estos podemos
aplicar el teorema de pitágoras para
encontrar con esta fórmula el tercer
lado revisemos más terminología el lado
más largo de este triángulo rectángulo
este lado de aquí el opuesto al ángulo
recto este lado designado por la letra
sea aquí se llama hipotenusa y
usa una palabra demandante para un
concepto tan simple el lado más largo de
un triángulo rectángulo de lo opuesto al
ángulo recto se llama hipotenusa ahora
que ya conocemos el teorema de pitágoras
vamos a aplicarlo vamos a usarlo porque
bueno una cosa es conocer algo y otra
cosa mucho más entretenida es aplicarlo
digamos que tenemos el siguiente
triángulo
déjame dibujarlo mucho más claro tenemos
este triángulo es un triángulo
rectángulo y supongamos que este lado
tiene una longitud de 9 y este otro lado
una longitud de 7 y que queremos saber
cuál la longitud de este lado llamémosle
lado se como ya vimos en este caso se es
la hipotenusa es el lado más largo y
como ya sabemos la suma de los cuadrados
de estos dos lados va a ser igual al
cuadrado de ese entonces por el teorema
de pitágoras tenemos que 9 al cuadrado
más 7 al cuadrado va a ser igual a se
cuadrada 9 al cuadrado es igual a 81 más
7 al cuadrado es igual a 49 y esto
cuando nos va a dar 81 más 49 80 más 40
y 120 19 10 esto va a ser igual a 130
deja de poner lo mejor de esta manera
esto de aquí es igual a 130 y aquí
tenemos que esto va a ser igual
entonces cuál es el valor de ese dejame
escribirlo por aquí tenemos que ser
cuadrada es igual a 130 o lo que
equivale a c igual a la raíz cuadrada de
130 y observa que solo estoy tomando la
raíz principal pues se al ser una
distancia tiene que ser positiva
no podemos tomar la raíz negativa por lo
que estamos tomando la raíz principal
vamos a tratar de simplificar el radical
extrayendo sus factores 130 lo podemos
descomponer como 2 por 65 a la vez que
65 lo puedo descomponer como 5 por 13
todos los factores de 130 son primos por
lo cual lo podemos simplificar más este
valor ya está en su forma más simple por
lo cual se es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 130 hagamos otro de estos problemas
voy a dejar aquí el teorema de pitágoras
para que veamos a qué nos estamos
refiriendo y voy a hacer mi triángulo
por acá supongamos que tenemos un
triángulo que se ve más o menos así
veamos este es ahora nuestro triángulo
este es nuestro ángulo recto
y supongamos que este lado de aquí le
voy a llamar a este lado de aquí tiene
una longitud de 21 mientras que este
otro lado tiene una longitud de 35 y
quizás de buenas a primeras podrías
decir bueno para encontrar a lo que hago
es sumo 21 al cuadrado más 35 al
cuadrado y así puede encontrar a pero
observa que en este caso 35 es la
hipotenusa aquí se es igual a 35 es el
lado más largo de este triángulo
rectángulo en este caso el teorema de
pitágoras nos dice que al cuadrado más
el cuadrado del otro lado del otro lado
corto en este caso 21 más 21 al cuadrado
es igual al cuadrado de la hipotenusa
que en este caso es 35 al cuadrado
tienes que recordar siempre que la se
cuadra da a la cual se refiere el
teorema es el lado más largo del
triángulo el lado opuesto al ángulo
recto este es el lado que está opuesto
al ángulo recto así a cuadrada más 21 al
cuadrado es igual a 35 al cuadrado que
tenemos entonces
1 al cuadrado estoy intentado a sacar la
calculadora pero no voy a hacerlo a mano
21 x 21 es igual 1 por 21 es 21 tenemos
cero aquí 2 por 21 es 42 esto nos da 441
35 al cuadrado de nueva cuenta atentado
a usar la calculadora pero no 35 por 35
5 por 5 25 llevamos 25 por 315 y 2 17 17
bajamos un 0 3 por 5 15 llevamos 13 x 39
y una 10 hacemos la suma 11 no voy a
hacerlo como debe ser 5 y 0 5 7 5 12
llevamos una una y una son dos y una
unos 1.225 que tenemos entonces tenemos
que a cuadrada más 441 es igual a 35 al
cuadro que 2002
225 restamos entonces 441 de ambos lados
estamos 441 ambos lados y tenemos aquí
esto se hace 0 sólo nos queda cuadrada y
del lado derecho que nos queda vamos a
hacer esta diferencia tenemos 1 para 54
ahora vamos a restar no mejor voy a
hacerlo más claro déjame escribir esto
más claro
vamos a restar entonces 441 ambos lados
del lado izquierdo se cancelen nos queda
a cuadrada del lado derecho que tenemos
vamos a hacer la diferencia 1 si es
menor a 54 no es menor a 2 tenemos que
tomar prestado 1 para que esto sea
entonces 12 luego tenemos que 4 no es
menor a 1 entonces de nueva cuenta
tomamos prestado 1 para poner este de
acá como 11 y ahora si hacemos la resta
1 para 5 es 4 4 para 12 es 8 y 4 para 11
es 7 cuadrada es igual a 784 y esto
equivale a que a
es igual a la raíz de 784 y de nueva
cuenta estoy tentado a sacar la
calculadora pero no no la voy a sacar
descomponga mos 184 en factores tenemos
que esto es 2 por 392 y 2 por 392 es
igual a 784
de acuerdo luego 392 lo podemos
descomponer como 2 por 196 196 dejame
checar 2 % 90 382 por 612 si es 392 y
luego 196 los componemos como 2 por
2 x 98 2 x 98
nos da 196 sigamos hacia abajo 98 es 2
por 49 dos por 49 y 49 ya sabemos a que
es igual que tenemos aquí 2 por 2 por 2
por 2 2 a la cuarta que es 16 por lo
cual es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 16
por 49 y elegí estos números porque
ambos son cuadrados perfectos y esto es
igual
a la raíz de 16 que es 4 por la raíz de
49 que es 7 4 por 7 es 28 así que este
lado de aquí es igual a 28 por el
teorema de pitágoras hagamos uno más de
estos problemas nunca está de más seguir
practicando dibujemos entonces otro
triángulo ahora lo va a ser grande este
es mi triángulo aquí tenemos el ángulo
recto y digamos que este lado mide 24
este lado 12 y este lado lo llamamos b
de nueva cuenta identificamos cuál es el
lado más largo el lado opuesto al ángulo
de 90 grados y podrías decir bueno yo no
sé si es el lado más largo
no conozco cómo sé que este es el más
largo en estos casos ya sabemos que es
el lado opuesto al ángulo de 90 grados
así que si esta es la hipotenusa
entonces este al cuadrado más este al
cuadrado va a ser igual a 24 al cuadrado
por el teorema de pitágoras tenemos que
b cuadrada más 12 al cuadrado es igual a
al cuadrado ahora restando 12 al
cuadrado ambos lados tenemos del lado
izquierdo es igual adecuada del lado
derecho es igual a 24 al cuadrado menos
12 al cuadrado 12 al cuadrado de 144 así
es que b es igual a la raíz de 24 al
cuadrado menos 12 al cuadrado
nuevamente intentado usar la calculadora
y boyacá en la tentación hagámoslo
el último que hicimos fue tan doloroso
aún me estoy recuperando que tenemos
entonces la raíz de 24 al cuadro menos
12 al cuadrado esto es igual a
24 78 déjame hacerlo por partes vamos a
sacar primero 24 al cuadrado menos 12 al
cuadrado esto nos da igual a 432 b es
igual entonces a la raíz cuadrada de 432
y factor hicimos esto de nueva cuenta ya
vimos cuál es el resultado pero quizás
podemos simplificar el radicando así que
esto es igual a 2 por 216 y 216 creo que
es un cuadro perfecto déjame checar la
raíz cuadrada de 216 no no es cuadrado
perfecto continuemos con el proceso 216
lo puede escribir como 2 por ciento 8
108 lo puede escribir como 4 por deja de
ver 4 por 25 100 por 27 4 por 27 y 27 lo
puede subir como 9 por 3 que tenemos
aquí
2 x 2 x 4 esto es 16 esto de aquí es 16
9 y 3 está bien déjame checar lo estoy
usando una calculadora distinta 16 x 9 x
3 es igual a 432 entonces b es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 16 x 9 x 3 lo cual
es igual la raíz cuadrada 16 es igual a
4 la raíz de 9 straits y lo nos queda
dentro del radical 3 esto va a ser igual
a 12 raíz de 3 tenemos entonces que b es
igual a 12 raíz de 3 espero que esto te
haya sido útil